well okay i have to mention it because  it's amazing but your hair is awesome oh  thank you yeah i just got a haircut i i  was trying to get out i did after i  finished jackie who's got this really  kind of terrible 90s haircut plus this  uh annoying mustache um that i can't  wait to take off by the way but i'm  almost i'm about three days away from  being able to take it off i think it  looks so cool thank you but uh um i  think here she's been very nice about it  but i think she's kind of over it i  think she's  kind of like when are we going to move  out of 70s porn  i didn't want to say it but i was like  you didn't want to i kind of can hear  like when you walked in i heard music it  was good  but your hair is like fantastic so ever  does your hair oh well done  [Music]  you